This is Jocko podcast number 88 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
I went into a public house to get a pint of beer.
The Public Guinea epon says,
we serve no redcoats here.
The girls behind the bar,
they laughed and giggled,
fit to die.
I outs to in to the streets again and to myself says,
I owe.
It's Tommy this and Tommy that and Tommy go away.
But it's,
thank you Mr. Atkins.
When the band begins to play,
when the band begins to play my boys,
the band begins to play.
Oh,
it's,
thank you Mr. Atkins.
When the band begins to play,
I went into a theater as sober as could be.
They gave a drunk civilian room,
but they hadn't known for me.
They sent me to the gallery or round the music halls.
But when it comes to fight and Lord,
they shoved me in the stalls for,
it's Tommy,
this and Tommy that and Tommy wait outside.
But it's special train for Atkins.
When the troopers on the tide,
the troop ships on the tide.
My Boys,
Oh,
it's special train for Atkins when the troopers on the tide.
Okay.
Yes.
Making Maka uniforms that guard you while you sleep is cheaper than them.
Uniforms in their starvation,
cheap and hustling.
Drunken soldiers when they're going larger bit is five times better business
than parade and in full kit.
Then it's Tommy,
this and Tommy that and Tommy,
how's your soul?
But it's thin red line of Arrows.
When the drums begin to roll,
the drums begin to roll.
My boys that drums begin to roll.
Oh,
it's thin red line of Arrows.
When the drums begin to roll.
We aren't no thin red arrows.
No,
we aren't.
No black guards too.
But single men in barracks most remarkable like you.
And if sometimes our conduct is in all your fancy paints,
why single men in barracks don't grow into plaster saints while it's Tommy,
this and Tommy that and Tommy fall behind.
But it's,
please walk in the front,
sir.
When there's trouble in the wind,
when there's trouble in the wind,
my boys,
there's trouble in the wind.
Oh,
it's please walk to the front.